STEVE: WELCOME BACK, EVERYONE.
THERE WAS ONCE A TIME WHEN THEY
FOUGHT FOR WOMEN'S LIBERATION
AND THE EXPLOSION OF CREATIVITY
AND MUSIC.
IT WAS UNDENIABLY A POWERFUL AND
HEARTFELT EXPRESSION OF FREEDOM.
THOSE REVOLUTIONS WERE DRIVEN BY
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEY WERE ON
THE LEFT.
LOOK WHERE THE LEFT IS TODAY.
INSTEAD OF FREEDOM THEY STAND
FOR CONTROL.
THEY ARE THE NEW PURITANS
MARCHING AROUND AND TELLING THEM
HOW THEY BEHAVE.
YOU SEXISM OR RACISM OR TRANCE
PHOBIA.
OF COURSE THEY ARE WRONG.
THE WAY YOU FIGHT THOSE THINGS
IS THROUGH ACTIVISM.
NOT THE BRAIN DEAD MIND CONTROL
FACT
TACTICS OF THE NEW PURITAN ON
THE LEFT.
THEY TELL YOU WHAT YOU ARE
ALLOWED TO DO AND SAY.
IF YOU TRANSGRESS YOU ARE
SHAMED.
THEY TALK ABOUT DIVERSITY AND
CRUSH THE MOST IMPORTANT
DIVERSITY OF ALL.
THE DIVERSITY THAT'S THE
FOUNDATION OF HUMAN PROGRESS.
THE DECIDE
THE DIVIDE
THE DIVERE
THE DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT.
THERE IS NO THOUGHT BUT
CONFORMITY.
THEY IMPOSED THEIR NARROW
MINDEDNESS.
THEY ARE TAKING OVER THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY WILL PROBABLY NOMINATE ONE
OF THEIR OWN AS THE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE AND DESERVETIVELY
LOSE.
THEY WILL NOT WIN BECAUSE THEY
HEAT
HAAT
YOUNG PEOPLE HATE BEING TOLD
WHAT TO DO.
THERE WILL BE A REVOLT.
SO, WHILE THE DEMOCRATS MIGHT
THINK THEIR PURITAN TAKER IS
GOOD POLITICS TODAY BUT THEY
WILL COME BACK AND PIET
WILL COME BACK AND BIET
WILL COME BACK AND BITT
WILL COME BACK AND BITE THEM IN
THE END.
IT'S DEEP AND STRONG AND
HEARTFELT.
THE LEFT CARRIES ON WITH
IT'S A